Steve Baker thanks for making time to
meet you here at Harvard still the best
university in the world and can you tell
a little bit more about you know the
interest of your skull rework Anderson
and what is that you're working on and
why I'm interested in human nature and
fortunately that covers many topics i
have written on everything from how to
write well to why languages have
irregular verbs to the historical trends
in war peace murder and genocide to
visual cognition how we form mental
images how we recognize shapes and cases
and one of the great advantages of being
a psychologist is that you can write
about all of a top these topics because
they all have to do with you in nature
and you think that because you know a
few other fields like philosophers or
theologians who claim also you know to
know everything also difference well
philosophy is very much related to
psychology and of course it was
philosophers who first raised questions
about the nature of human nature I don't
think there is a sharp division between
the field of philosophy of the field of
psychology their philosophical questions
Veronica logical questions philosophical
questions about the nature of ideas how
they're logically related to each other
psychological questions are more
empirical how does the human brain come
to think certain kinds of thoughts and
have certain kinds of values but that in
my experience they've all been closely
related you have been so extremely kind
to accept our invitation to be one of
the speakers of the Nexus conference on
November 12 what will save the world
your world famous you're very much in
demand you're extremely busy man why did
you accept the invitation to come to
Amsterdam make time and to be present
and speak at their conference well I
like the questions it is it could be no
bigger question and what will save the
world I don't think the day they will
save the world
bringing utopia to earth but I think the
world can be improved and that would be
the version of a question that I am very
much interested in because I think the
world has improved and I can't improve
further all of the most famous people in
the world of psychology Sigmund Freud
what I guess much less optimistic if I
understand him well he was especially
interested in the question you know why
are things going wrong all the time we
will also have religious people and
probably they will say well it goes
wrong because with something like
original sin on a secular level Freud
ballpoint and the dark side of human
nature why do you think it's going wrong
so often yes well like like Freud I do
believe that human nature has a dark
side I believe that being a member of a
civilized society evolves compromises
and discontent sis for it so famously
put I think that aspects of human nature
inevitably come into conflict with the
aspects of human nature and other people
I don't think that men and women want
exactly the same thing I don't think the
parents and children want exactly the
same thing even close friends don't
always want the same thing there's
always tension there are always
conflicts of interest that's why there's
great literature that's why there's
tragedy on the other hand one component
of human nature is the ability to pose
and solve problems or to add to
communicate our solutions to other
people by a language thanks to writing
we can accumulate good ideas we can try
out ways of improving human life keep
the ones that work discard the ones that
don't work learn from our mistakes learn
from our tragedies and bit by bit figure
out ways in which we can minimize the
effects of human conflict and I think
the data show that we've been doing it
another reason that Freud was so
pessimistic is that he was situated in
one of the worst times of human history
the years following the First World War
which he lived through and immediately
preceding the Second World War he lived
the angelus his daughter was arrested by
the nazis he escaped from the Nazis just
in time to spend the last year of his
life in London and so he saw a clouds
gathering for one of the worst
interludes in human history the Second
World War now and indeed if the world
that Freud lived and had continued none
of us should be an optimist because that
was those were dark days indeed and of
course there were predictions after the
Second World War that the two world wars
were just beginning of an escalating
series World War three was inevitable it
would be even worse because of nuclear
weapons we are now more than 70 years
after the end of World War two and world
war three did not happen no nuclear
weapon has been used since Nagasaki the
world has become more democratic more
affluent more free more peaceful in the
70 years that's no guarantee that it
will continue no one can prophecy the
future I don't have the gift of
clairvoyance in order to be able to see
into the future but it shows that the
kind of doom that many intellectuals
felt after World War two is not
inevitable there are actions that we can
take that reduce the risks and
fortunately we have been taking